KORY JEFFREY: Welcome, everyone.
We are at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I have in the studio with
me Cody, a chief astronaut
at RockIT.
Thank you for joining me, Cody.
CODY VOELLINGER: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So what
is RockIT Recruiting?
What do you guys do?
CODY VOELLINGER: So RockIT has
been around for four years.
And we partner with
local VCs and help
build their portfolio companies
when it becomes time for them
to start scaling their
engineering teams.
So at this point, we've helped
hundreds of different startups
in the Bay Area hire hundreds
of engineers, product managers,
and designers.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So do you guys have
a specific philosophy
about how you go
about doing that?
CODY VOELLINGER: Yeah.
We are bringing recruiting
back to its old school,
traditional roots
while using cutting
edge technology to do so.
So what I mean by that is
bringing the relationship back
to recruiting.
We've got our office here
in SoMa at 5th and Harrison.
And we have sponsored
hackathon teams, given them
crushed velour tracksuits
with branded RockIT Recruiting
to represent us.
We've sponsored
tech trivia events
at local pubs like pub trivia.
We just did an interview
training series
with Gayle McDowell, who
wrote "Cracking the Coding
Interview."
So a whole series of
events to build our brand
within the developer
and startup community.
And that's on the
candidate side of things.
On the client side, every
company that we work with,
we've visited their office.
We've sat down with
the founders, the heads
of engineering, and
talked to them about,
what do you need to
build a successful team?
And how can we help with that?
And the reason we
take all the time
to make those two connections
is because hiring is
difficult and time consuming.
And finding a job is
stressful and time consuming.
And so we want to take
all of the pain out
of that for both sides and help
to make a high quality match.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty cool.
So what is the craziest thing
that somebody's ever asked you
to do for a recruiting purpose?
CODY VOELLINGER:
This actually dates
back to my time
recruiting in Tokyo,
which is where I started
my recruiting career.
I found a job for a lady.
And we went out for
a celebration dinner.
And she very
seriously said, Cody,
you've done such an amazing
job finding me a company that
matches exactly what I need.
I'd like you to
recruit me a husband.
KORY JEFFREY: Really?
CODY VOELLINGER: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So
small step, I suppose,
between recruiting for a job
and recruiting for a husband.
CODY VOELLINGER:
Everyone compares
interviewing and hiring
to dating all the time.
That analogy is very prevalent.
So yeah.
She went for it.
I had to politely decline.
KORY JEFFREY: That's awesome.
CODY VOELLINGER:
But it was funny.
KORY JEFFREY: But
being serious, there
is a pretty close connection
with how personal it
is on both sides.
So finding a job,
finding an employer.
How do you do that at scale?
Because obviously, as
your company grows,
personal relationships
can be more
difficult to do on a one
on one basis like this.
How do you do that?
CODY VOELLINGER: That is tough.
That's part of why we exist.
So as a startup, you're
10, 20, 30, 40 people.
You don't have time to be
sending thousands of emails,
having hundreds of conversations
to make those four or five
hires with people
that are going to fit.
And that's why you
outsource that to us.
So recruiting is a
value add because it
saves time and
provides a service
to both sides of the equation.
That's why companies
rely on us to do that.
And we don't have a solution,
other than a lot of hard work.
There is no silver bullet
to automate the recruiting
process.
One of the things that
we've done recently
that we're pretty excited
about is we just brought
in an expert storyteller.
He was an editor at Time
magazine for a long time.
He's been a part of startups.
And he's done a couple
training sessions with our team
on how do you tell
a compelling story.
So that when we go to
visit the companies,
even if they don't have their
own compelling story created,
we can create that for them.
And we can help them to
distribute that message
and identify who's actually
going to be a quality fit so we
can make that introduction.
KORY JEFFREY: I
mean, you have seen
quite a few technical people
get matched and find their dream
job.
You've also seen quite a few
probably not be successful.
What would your advice
be to technical people?
We have quite a few technical
people that watch this channel.
What would your advice be
to somebody who's really
looking to find that dream job?
What is it that they could do to
make themselves more appealing
or to find that right match?
CODY VOELLINGER: That's
a tough question.
I don't know that
there's anything
you have to do to make
yourself "more appealing,"
quote, unquote.
I mean, if you haven't
interviewed in a long time,
then I would recommend doing
some practice mock interviews
just to get comfortable.
Or start out your interviewing
with a couple companies
you're not as interested in
almost as a practice round.
But you're not trying
to trick someone.
To go back to the dating
and marriage analogy,
you want to be yourself.
And you want to find
a company that's
also going to be upfront
with you about what
their expectations are so
that you can stay there
for the long term.
So of course this
is self serving.
But honestly, if I were
going to look for a job,
I would look for a
well-connected recruiter
because, as I mentioned,
we've worked with hundreds
of different companies.
We've been to all
of those offices.
We've sat down
with the founders.
A single job searcher doesn't
have the time to do that.
And so let someone else be
a first round filter for you
and then suggest likely
connections based
on your interests.
And finding a recruiter
that you can trust
and you can partner
with is difficult.
And so I recommend you
talk to your friends,
talk to your network.
Ask who they've had
good experiences with.
And value those
recommendations really highly.
KORY JEFFREY: Cool.
So Founder World.
What excites you
about coming here?
Why are you here today?
Why did you speak?
CODY VOELLINGER: Jermaine Dupri.
I'm sitting in his seat, man.
KORY JEFFREY: It's
still warm, right?
CODY VOELLINGER: It's still
warm from Jermaine Dupri.
I love Guy Kawasaki.
I've seen him speak
a couple times.
Tim Draper has some
insane, out there ideas
that he's actually
implementing, like slicing up
California and Draper
University and everything.
So there's just a lot of
great ideas and minds.
And then, for those of
you who can't be here,
there's so much energy
buzzing around this place
and excitement over people
starting new companies.
And that's fun for
us because we get
to just take that all in, bottle
it up, and take that passion
into our jobs of helping these
people build their companies
and helping people find
jobs that they're going
to be really passionate about.
So we talk to so
many engineers who
are tired of being
a cog in a machine,
not feeling like
they have an impact.
And so to help those
folks find something
that they're going
to love to wake up
and come into work early and
really put their heart into,
that's exciting for us.
And that's what kind
of keeps us motivated
and keeps us going
as recruiters.
KORY JEFFREY: So
obviously, you guys
are very involved in the
Bay Area, I believe, right?
You said in the Valley.
What is the number
one position that's
most sought after that you
see from startups today?
CODY VOELLINGER: We have a
giant whiteboard in our office
that lists all of the positions
and all of the companies
that we're recruiting for.
The one that's probably the
longest list at the moment--
and it fluctuates.
It ebbs and flows.
The one that's the longest
right now is probably
front end engineers.
And I would say that's because
every company needs a front end
engineer.
So while someone
might be working
with Scala or Go or
Node.js on the back end,
they all need JavaScript
engineers on the front end.
That's probably the most
in demand at the moment.
KORY JEFFREY: And
then I'll end it with,
what is your favorite
Google technology?
CODY VOELLINGER: Google Maps.
KORY JEFFREY: Google Maps.
CODY VOELLINGER: Google Maps,
because I would literally
be lost without it.
KORY JEFFREY: I could
agree with that, actually.
That's a great answer.
Cody, thank you very
much for joining us.
CODY VOELLINGER: Thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
CODY VOELLINGER: Appreciate it.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you guys for joining us.
This is at Founder World in San
Francisco, and my name is Kory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]